okay
so I think it's up on the big screen and
I really can't see anyone due to the
bright light there but I think there are
some people yeah
okay cool welcome everyone
um great to see so many attendees on
this year's NDC a huge shout out to the
organizers and the volunteers and the
sponsors for making this happen would
definitely be not be possible without
any of them so my name is hans christian
29 years old i have a wife and two boys
back in bergen the western part of
norway for those of you who are not
local yeah and they're a huge part of my
life and I just want to take the time to
like say thank you to my wife who takes
care of the kids and all of the things
back home when I'm out traveling and NDC
so previously I used to be a software
engineer at the new eating vegan
tracking Association TNT where I were
responsible for their open data platform
and for each I know for those of you who
are have been hiking I know they
recently launched an updated version and
I have some friends over at shortcut
that made a new mobile app so be sure to
check that out afterwards
and if you are planning your summer
vacation that that would be a great tool
to if you want to do some hiking in
Norway or if my talk get boring then you
can browse there and see something so I
joined every three years ago I went from
30 colleagues to 9000 colleagues that
was kind of a cultural shock and if you
guys followed then at least the new
region tech news every and quieto
announced their intention to emerge
during the year and after that will be
the largest IT organization in the north
Europe so I started out as just a
consultant within every and quickly
realized that the practices we had were
doing at the tracking Association where
where we were a very small team
we're not that much being practiced
within a tree so I took upon it myself
to proclaim myself as the devil practice
lead and after a while people I started
referring me to as that and a while
after that it was formalized that I had
that that role and could spend a lot of
my time working internally and working
with our customers how to kind of use
the DevOps practices and methodologies
I'm also an avid open source contributor
and enthusiasts been on the node.js
foundation been helping them with build
and deploy and if any one of you are no
J's users and docker users I've been
part of the team creating the official
node.js image so today I'm going to talk
about a project we've been working with
for the last couple of months last year
actually it's called build a bunk and
I'm going to like give a brief
introduction what this builder what is
it actually about the architecture
behind jumping right in and digging into
how it what is what does it take to make
a new mobile blankie
then we'll talk about build and deploy
as well as runtime and operations
so villa bunk is a new challenger bank
for all of norway its mobile only bank
so we won't have any traditional desktop
website where you can log in and do your
banking things it's owned solely bar by
spa bumpkin West but it operates
otherwise completely independently it's
completely autonomous has its own
leadership its own developers its own
technical staff support staff and so on
and reports directly to the CEO of their
parent company yeah so they're kind of
like the differential factors here is to
create the best and the most awesome
mobile experience for banking or banking
customers and competitive more to get
more today more touches with automatic
rent adjustments so no need to call your
bank and ask them to sit down there the
rent if it's been changed this should
happen automatically and we believe that
customers shouldn't be have beer have to
like call their banks every now and then
to get the fair rate that they deserve
and then delivering value adds and
integrations on top of the traditional
transactions and payments and what you
are used to in normal banking situations
so the timeline was this August of 2018
build a bunk was just an idea where the
head of the bank went to the corporate
the the board of directors and proposed
an IDE to create a challenger Bank and
keep in mind this was the ID and the
reason that this was kind of like was a
propose at all is sort of the PSD to
open banking directive that is going
into effect in
September but he got approval and
started assembling a team and during the
fall we had the team in place and by
January it was in full effect and then
by June third we launched and that's
only ten months from going from just an
idea no code at all no specifications
nothing just date and kind of the
overall rounds that what are we going to
build here and I must say that's I've
never been on a product where in this
kind of like industry at least that
where we were able to pull that off so
the only way we could have achieved this
was to scope down scope down scope down
and only deliver a minimal Viable
Product a truly minimal Viable Product
which means that of course since we were
mobile only and we were weren't we
shouldn't have any like manual
procedures and calling in and yada yada
all of the onboarding had to be done on
the device on the mobile phone and then
of course you need to show your
transactions your banking histories you
need to be able to do payments you need
some management of your credit cards or
payment cards and then we also had push
notifications for when there are new
transactions or there anything have
exciting happening and also invoice
canning so you didn't have to type in
the kid Nomar number and account number
and so on you can just scan your invoice
if you're still had paper invoice so
this was the feature set that we
launched in with June 3rd and during the
summer now and until we are open for
everyone so do you and third be open for
our like better customers we have a
waiting list and we are onboarding if
100 customers at the time during
December but that's in September in the
fall we'll open for everyone and you're
at that time we are working on
subscription management working on much
richer transaction details where you can
really see that what are the
transactions and payments about not only
a cryptic name and and what's in a
normal bank statement and also tools to
help manage your economy so this was the
team in reality they probably looked a
little bit more like that we have a CTO
we have two people doing primarily UX
and design we have a front-end developer
since we only have the landing site we
don't have that much front-end developer
we have at you guys doing back-end
development q guys on infrastructure we
have an Android team and an iOS team and
that's it this is the complete technical
build a team but it wouldn't be possible
for all the work that's spoken converse
the rest of the open banking and PSD to
team there has has done because we are
building on top of or building against
their api's banking APIs in order to do
the core banking functionality I'll get
more into that so these are the key
principles so our new CTO was very vocal
when he he started that these are the
principles that we are going to do work
within we want to empower people yeah
everyone on the team should have their
say and be able to like if they want to
take charge on a functionality or on a
feature they should be able to do
awesome work so make people awesome and
the second part was make it okay to fail
make it safe to fail you should in order
to kind of do experience and B go fast
and lean and rapidly we
you need a safety safety net and they're
never like one person in at fault if
anything if something goes wrong it's
always always the team's team that wins
or fails we should strive to experiment
and learn rapidly so coming up with new
ideas putting that into effect and
getting feedback and then deciding
whether or not we should go forward this
not sit down in a committee and design
and kind of think long and hard of if
you should do this or not and that's
also in line that deliver value
continuously it doesn't matter if it's
the most exciting and best feature in
the world if no one is using it it's
potentially just something cost so it
needs to be done in an iterative process
and always be releasing functionalities
when they're done so scoping down making
the features as small as possible and
then getting them out the door so here
are the latest stats leading up to our
release June 3rd as you can see so on
the left-hand side you have the number
of commits total in the organization and
then you have repositories for different
components and subsystems so as you can
see it kind of like grows and grows and
grows in a steady rate until June and we
couldn't we are expecting this to kind
of like flatten a little bit out during
the summer when they're on vacation but
continue during the fall so this if you
if we rewind 10 months when it was just
an ID or had our CTO toe ball and came
to some of the guys and with this idea
he had kind of like got accepted that we
were building this Bank and he had got
the date
twenty first thirty 31st of May or
beginning of June back that it had to be
done by then it had to be ready there
and starting onboarding new customers to
bank and he asked how is this East as
possible can we do this in ten months
and if so how and what he got back was
that yes we believe this is possible if
we are using Google Cloud and I'll get
into why what them and when that when he
got that answer back within six weeks we
had made a notice to announce to Cena
that we were going to use Google Cloud
and set up and we're starting to work
and and he said to me that having a
deadline like this forces the
technicians or developers to think new
and it also forces the leadership to
listen when they say this is how we need
to do it they need to listen to that and
take the appropriate decisions so why
did we choose Google cloud at two
reasons
the first one is firebase which is a
mobile app developers suit of products
by Google cloud and the third one is
their managed Cuban it is offering so
the current architecture or the
architecture is quite simple we have
mobile devices we have Android and iOS
applications or Bank Bank app
applications for the bank they are
talking with firebase so they get all of
their the customer data from firebase
use because customer information
transactions accounts credit cards you
name it everything is stored there and
whenever they want to do a new
transaction or they want to update some
of their information that is written
back to firebase from firebase then
it goes into our back-end systems which
is running on cabinets engine and then
again we talk with the open banking PSD
to of AP ice at spa bulk in West so
firebase can be kind of divided in and
three main categories at least the ones
the products we are currently using so
we have fire store which is there no SQL
database for mobile and web applications
for in fact it during most of the
development of the bank it was in
preview and just in time for release
just a couple of months before we
released it went out of preview and into
general availability and we got SLA so I
was fortunate so also it has cloud
functions serverless functions that you
can that triggers whenever anything is
updated or deleted or insert it or
anything we can trigger functions and do
something with that and it also has its
own authentication system so we don't
need to deal with how do we securely
authenticate the user with a survey with
the firebase service that is all handled
for us so for the little bit more
operational side it delivers it has what
I call crashlytics which is a crash
reporting tool so whenever there is an
error in the application that gets
automatically reported and we get nice
dashboards and alerts and root cause
analysis performance monitoring what how
is the client how are they are they
experiencing the bank we are built and
also there is like a test lab where you
can test new functionality in a headless
way and before it's released to our
customers and the third one it comes
with its own messaging system so it
enables us to deliver push notifications
and in-app notifications without having
to deal a lot with with any
infrastructure is just an API
analytics for getting metrics and data
for all of the usage and also remote
configuration where we can do a/b
testing push different configurations
the different set of users and turn
functionality often on so the firestore
works that is so when we started setting
up the project or creating these
applications so what would happily took
thicknose a couple of days weeks months
maybe to set up like a back end where we
can communicate and start getting data
writing data back and getting that
performant and secure and all of that
that was done in 30 minutes so firebase
provides us the SDKs necessarily to do a
bi-directional communication with the
firestore so we can instantly get all of
the data that for this particular
customer and we can just write it back
and it will it all happens by the SDK it
also has like since it's a it's a very
rich and graph like no SQL database
where you can have nested structures and
kind of have a structure that makes
sense so we for instance we have
accounts and accounts can have
transactions then can have credit cards
the economic no customers can have
transactions and credit cards and
accounts and then you can nest deeply
into that so no schema no problems right
no no Seema no new problems so this is
kind of the inevitable when you are
reading and writing directly to your
datastore you are bound to have income
abilities between your clients different
clients so we have a Android client and
iOS client and they need to kind of
write the data the same if we're
supposed to like be able to jump from
one type of client to the next and also
between versions how do we do scheme
evolutions how do we do data versioning
and so on that isn't handled by fire
first or at all
and that's where open API specification
comes in
so when after a while we well we saw
this coming that this would eventually
be a problem if we were supposed to like
create a new version of the the credit
card data object or if we are to ensure
that the user object is written in the
same way on an android client and on the
iOS client plant we need to start
defining what are the use of models what
are the fields what's the data types and
so on so the open API specification
allows us to kind of like using llamó
which everyone loves to create this is
how the account we want should look like
this is of the credit-card v1 and v2
should look like this payment should
look like and all of the different
objects and data types or objects that
we have in our file store and kind of
create objects or define definitions of
them and I'm from there we can generate
iOS client library android client
library go library and no J's library
and just consume that without having to
worry that is this writing this
different this object differently than
the other clients which leaves us today
I am the applications themselves both
the android client and the iris client
are of course native applications it's
kind of like this is our equivalent to a
brick and mortar shop or store so of
course they have to be built with care
and from scratch and using the native
implementations so the Android app is
written in code plain the iOS app is
written in Swift five and then using
Gradle and cocoa pods and and so on both
of them have are using server CI and
phosphene for deployment but of course
like the Android app ends up in Google
Play Store and the iOS app ends up in
test flight and then in
store so that was the firebase part and
the second part for why we chose Google
Cloud was there Cuba needs suffering
so how many in the audience here use
Cuban it is and how many use it for
production yeah quite a few cool so it
shouldn't come as a surprise that the
most stable and the best place to run
your Cuban is cluster is in on Google's
own offering and that comes since they
have 15 years kind of ahead of everyone
else because they sort of invented this
on not only communities but the lower
levels abstractions or functionality in
the linux kernel's as well so kind of
they they had an advantage their error
is catching up and Amazon is probably
catching up as well so who will have to
see what how the market is in in one
year's time so I won't dig in too much
why or what community is I guess most
people here know what it is it's Greek
for the helmsman hence the wheel in the
logo it's a container Orchestrator so
when you have only one machine and one
container it's fine but what happens
when you have thousand containers on
hundreds and different machines how are
you going to manage that and it's based
or mirrored on Google's internal system
called Borg it runs in the cloud and
runs really well on bare metal as well
we have several customers using either
or their and it also supports multiple
container runtimes as well as windows
containers for those who are crazy
enough to to do that so but that the
beauty of of communities is that it
gives you this API it's mostly nice or
actually only an API and it doesn't
matter if this if it's backed by a huge
kubernetes cluster with hundreds and
hundreds of nodes and petabytes of
memory and TP use and GPUs and so on or
like I have in my spare room
rack of raspberry pies it's still the
same api's it doesn't it can't run that
many containers but it's the same API
nevertheless it doesn't matter if this
is on AWS or Azure or Google Cloud all
of them has certified Cuban it is
runtimes so you just click the button or
you just call the API or use the CLI and
boom you have a valid Cuban it's cluster
and of course there are some values at
the different providers provide but the
units actually has a conformance test
whether a couple of thousand tests that
the providers has to run and anyone in
the audience here and when using their
service should always also be able to
run the conformance test to see that it
is actually compliant with the Cuban 8
specification and they have to recertify
this for each new version in order to
kind of be able to call their service
something with the Cuba neatest name
yeah so API first it's very modular all
of the components are in fact
microservice all of the components
building up kubernetes and the third
thing that's really really important and
why we chose it is this self-healing
capability so if you configure your
application correctly you can be able to
sleep at night of course job is still on
you to kind of set up the correct health
checking and liveness probes and then
cuban it is will do at least the heavy
lifting and if things fails even even
though then maybe the whole world world
is failing so yeah so that's firebase
and cuban it's engine so we actually had
to split these two up in different
projects within in within Google Cloud
so projects are like accounts they're
different like separated namespaces that
was mostly due to limitation for
controlling access to giving users not
not the customers access but like
developers access be able to like go in
and use the fibrous products it's only
that it required them to have all
sort of other access that we weren't
like very keen on giving so we split
this up and your thought has very nice
where authentication is just seamlessly
working between different projects so no
big deal so but like this is the very
very simple architecture of course it
can't be that simple and yeah you're
right so we do have some functions as
well as I kind of alluded here firebase
has this really really really really
nice integration where it can have
pieces of code triggering whenever
something is changed so you can have
functions and you can attach triggers to
them and say that if this object is
updated or there's a new customer here
or a new transaction there run this code
for me please and ideally we would like
to use the pub/sub functionality in
Google Cloud and ideally or initially we
did use it but then compliance started
asking really no not nasty question but
they started asking the hard questions
that they are paid to do and toasters
where are the data living when you put
something on pub/sub and we said hmm
well Google says it's globally it's
somewhere on planet Earth and compliance
came back and said that ain't good
enough obviously so we had to find some
alternative and we ended up with nuts so
nuts is a high-performance messaging
system it of course offers publish and
subscribe pattern where you just like
send a message and forget about it and
but it also has a subscription-based
topic-based subscription system as well
where you can subscribe to a topic and
you know that in if you go down and you
come up again that you'll be able to
like continue very left off without
missing any messages and of course
that's important for our customers there
if they like put in a new transaction or
a payment of course they don't they
would like that to actually be carried
out and not
end up in in limbo what's very nice when
about gnats is that it's a single binary
everything go so it's very operational
very simplistic simple so very little
things that can be go wrong or or
libraries that are not the correct
versions and Jana it's actually quite a
number of years old
I wouldn't say very old but when I
looked back into their release history I
found commits and release in 2013 so
that kind of gives them some credibility
to not just like going away they are
also an official CN CF project so along
with communities and Prometheus and
linker D and n boy and so on so on Nats
is there as well and actually June this
June June and in the beginning of June
they release the version 2.0 of the Nats
streaming system or the not system so
then we start looking into how should we
hopefully like run this because like we
until that time we kind of like okay all
of the infrastructure parts that's
managed by Google we just have we just
have it as a service
let me started looking into the queue
bonitas operator pattern which is a way
of building Kuban it is native
applications so this isn't something
that we had to do but we were leveraging
it so it's a it's that it's two things
it's extending the kubernetes api so the
communities for those who you have
familiar communities you have your pods
your services and deploys and ingress
and so on but you can extend this with
your own api objects within each CD and
the Kuban it is api so that's called
custom resource definitions and then if
you have this custom resource definition
kubernetes isn't managing that if you
have some some api object kubernetes
doesn't know how to handle that so you
need a service or or deployment within
communities that is actually april were
able to handle that object so that's
called a controller that runs inside
Kuban it is
and then you can do something like this
this is that when for the Prometheus
operator if you have installed the
operator it extends the kubernetes api
and you are able to just say I want the
new Prometheus instance it says API
version monitoring caress that comm
slash we want and kind Prometheus and
that isn't there like a base or a normal
Cuba needs object that's these custom
resource definitions and the Prometheus
operator controller will handle that and
then create the necessary pods and
services and so on that will ultimately
end up as a Prometheus deployment and
it's it's very suitable for like these
when you go further than what typically
helm or ansible will do really they just
deploy it and then it's over it does all
of the lifecycle
it handles upgrade and recovery it's
built in if they start failing how
should it start restarting and data
migrations and so on so it's very
well-suited for complex applications
that cannot be defined just by a couple
of lines or hundred lines of
so the Nats operator that or the Nats
installation that we ended up with looks
something like this we have installed a
nuts operator it extends the Kuban e to
say PR with the nuts customer resource
definition and then there is a nuts
there's a nuts operator controller
running in its own namespace as a
deployment and as pods then we can go
ahead and say we want the new nuts
cluster so that's a new data type new at
the R type type in API since we have
extended that that's the operator will
then create the deployment as so as we
have specified and create a service so
we are able to kind of reach it then we
want to deploy an application that wants
to consume this nuts cluster here so we
start off by defining nuts service role
which is its enables us to kind of go
take a service account
and then give it some permissions within
nuts we want to have a secure way of
authenticating our applications to Ana
nuts message bus and what actions they
are allowed to do that so the operator
will then based on the the service role
that we have provided it will generate a
token that has those privileges and then
we can of course then we can do our
actual deployment and it's able to talk
with the nuts cluster so then we were
stuck with this so we had when something
were changed in firestore it triggered a
function and if that function had to
call our back-end services it had to go
through the message browser and remember
this is no longer pub/sub it's nuts and
it's running inside it's inside our
Cuban it's cluster there's a little bit
wrong in the picture here but the
functions don't have access to this
because the functions are running
globally on some other subnet and IP
that Google controls our or our
kubernetes cluster is running inside our
own VPC it's private network did not
accessible from the outside as it should
be and hence nuts is not accessible
there so first we thought of you well we
found this solace VPC access connector
which acts acts as a gateway which
enables functions to go pass through
this gateway in order to kind of access
not only cuban it is services but VMs
and so on running inside of a PC we then
also had to like well we would have done
some V PC pairing because functions are
not yet available in Europe North where
or main
applications are running it's running in
West one because that's the closest
place that has these functions and then
we realized that the surveillance
gateway was only accessible in the US so
we couldn't do anything of any of this
until I think it's q4 when this is
coming to Europe so for the time being
we had to revert all of that we had to
expose nuts via a load balancer had to
put on well that was in place before
like a client certificate and services
yet so both parties are authenticating
each other in addition we have the nuts
token that I previously talked about for
that the our back-end services uses well
so it's pretty strong authentication and
authorization guarantees but we would
ideally like to have this like only on
inside our private networks so then we
start also asking us ourself what if we
could run service functions inside Cuba
natives and actually you can
it's called que native it is service
containers on communities it's an open
source project built by Google IBM
reddit I were fortunate enough to have
lunch for them during cube Condor
extremely smart a couple of guys that
are working full time on this project
and it runs on top of SEO for those of
you familiar with the SEO service match
it has three parts it's this build
component that takes source code and
makes it into a container image so all
of the build you don't have to use
Jenkins or Travis or soku CI or whatever
you can just build this inside your Cuba
needs cluster and it's secure and
efficient way it has the serving
component that enables you to quickly
run up some image and then spin it down
when it's no longer needed and then the
venting component bridge is a general
eventing bus and they have implemented
or eventing specification and then
implementation for different eventing
system so you can have a Kafka topic and
you can have a service container
spinning up acting on that and when it's
done it terminates and it scales down to
zero you can have pub/sub you cannot
have firebase because that isn't
supported and it's it's own eventing
system so currently it wasn't really a
possibility yet but hopefully maybe it
would be and actually Cuban it is or
Google has a managed service for this
inside in their offering as well as with
sto they have a manage is to your
installation they also have a managed
Kane ATO and they have managed to call
it Google cloud run but it is K native I
was assured about that so moving on our
back in services 99% of them are written
in go its api's and functions and its
services running in our back-end so
whenever you have a new transaction or a
payment or we are fetching data or
whatever we are doing that's a go
service or go binary that's doing that
work
we have some synchronous calls in within
our back-end that's implemented at G RPC
and in some cases if we have to expose
this even further out its rest but we
like to use our G RPC and I'll get into
more why we chose go but there are no
frameworks involved this is just like
using the go standard library that's
there and of course like SDKs for
talking with firebase or real nuts or
whatever but no fancy or complicated
framework on top of that again and then
we have some node.js running as well
it's mainly for the Builder monkey and
know and some functions that where the
SDK for the firestore only has support
for the in the node.js SDK we are try to
be very rigorous adhering to the 12
factors that's originally developed by
Heroku I won't go through them but kind
of they are still as relevant today as
they were when they Annie
they thought thought of this I think
most of the people in the audience will
know them or they are adhering to them
either if they know them or not it's
becoming more and more standard
procedure so why go none of us had any
experience we go when we started we had
absolutely not ring written and at least
not in production or any system maybe
some of the guys I had liked
experimented a little bit myself but not
in any like big way it was mainly well
it delivers like best of both worlds
there are no there are no run times that
you need to install and upgrade and yada
yada yada so there's no VM there are no
Python interpreter no node an
interpreter still it's memory safe
unlike C and C++ where you can help all
of these memory issues it's it actually
builds in its own runtime when you
compile an application which is very
quick and efficient and you get a static
binary that you can actually cross
compile on all different targets and
then just move around as you like
concurrency is built-in as a base as a
first-class citizen
so they vary in the go mantra or
philosophy they have been very explicit
that multi-core is kind of like the way
forward and you you should your
application should be able to kind of
take advantage of that without doing
very fancy or like unsafe threading
things that should just be managed by
the programming language also it aims to
reduce the amount of typing you can see
the example here is just like the
shorthand version of declaring a new
variable and its value so this creates a
new variable with a type integer and
value for it too and it just in hairs it
knows it the compiler looks at what
value you are giving
here it can be a new object or whatever
this it knows the data types and then it
creates the appropriate type for the new
variable you are creating so this isn't
like we're in a node very just like have
a variable and it can be anything and
also and this is kind of the one of the
more controversial things and kind of
makes people like not like go ideally or
initially is that you have to deal with
errors errors are common they happen you
have to deal with that you cannot just
like throw it or like no this is this is
someone else's someone else have to deal
with this which ends up with not being
dealt with at all and you have all this
fun uncaught exceptions errors so in go
you have to deal with them and you have
all of these and it doesn't look that
pretty and when you first look at them
and but after a while you just get used
to that and it works really good so this
is a typical service if we have
something that are running and accepting
synchronous connections there's like a
very simple main function
that's pulls in there different
controllers and you just like yeah
handle requests on this path on this
path and this path and then start
listening on port 80 80 80 and the all
interfaces so this isn't this is built
right into the go standard library no
extra framework required at all so we
have a fairly otherwise a fairly typical
and software developer pipeline for our
back-end services all changes of course
have to go through gate we are using
circle CI for all the build and test and
deploy for our backing services
and yeah once it's pushed circle CI
starts chugging along fetching and
installing all the dependencies and
building the application then running
all sort of the unit tests and
integration tests and whatever you have
with syntax linting of course using sono
cloud for source code
scanning so the code that we we write we
have some rules and we have some we want
to have the quality they're as good as
possible so we're using so-so no cloud
to kind of go through and check that on
the fly whenever you propose as pull or
cast
so no cloud we'll do the scanning and we
use sneak for dependency checking or
scanning so all of the dependencies that
we depend on there it's go modules or
its NPM packages or whatever you have
sneaked we'll all my we'll check the
versions and check their vulnerability
of registry and then it will give you a
report so whenever you do a change it
will check that you're not introducing
new vulnerabilities and if there are
something that is discovered it will
automatically propose pull requests so
we believed we don't have a very large
or any security team we don't have an
operational team we rely mostly on the
on tools that need to do this work for
us and whenever there are something that
needs to be fixed the tools should
propose that and not give us 300 lines
of PDF where we have to go through and
look oh it's this module that we have to
upgrade and the last stage of course is
deploy so we we build an image we sign
it we put it in our registry and then we
use helm to do deploy to first test
cluster and then if everything looks
okay then we promote that to our
production cluster and it's the same
image that is running in both or we
build it once and deploy it many times
yeah no cuts no butts no coconuts
there's no shortcut you can't like oh I
just need to fix this in production no
ain't gonna fly you have to go through
gate and then fly ploy so we are master
branch should be always be be deployable
that's our mantra and using feature
toggling in order to selectively a turn
unfinished functionality on and off and
working on improving that and making the
business side more responsible for when
different
functionality should be available and to
what customers so last time I checked we
had we were well above 250 hours billed
hours within so go see right so we try
to use we don't want to have as you said
we are 15 technicians or developers
creating buildable and we then need to
using the computer for everything they
are cheap humans are not so whenever
there's like a boring repetitive things
that takes some minutes that is
something that the computer should do
and kind of like this is this is where
the rest of the team are it's build
hours in circle CI or in in Cuban
eighties so we are so this is how way
how far we ever with here we are
applications talking with firebase
triggering functions in calc function
going through notes and our banking
system in communities and then of course
we do have some we do have some
endpoints that are not it cannot go
through this asynchronously appear
either it's before before the customer
is a customer at all and they are in the
process of actually registering or they
won't need to get the token in order to
communicate where firebase or if we have
some api's that no are not well-suited
for like this asynchronous communication
and because as I mentioned initially
like we want to have the best mobile
experience we we do have to we want to
have very competitive loans and we also
want to deliver a lot of value adds on
top of the regular like banking
functionality that you're kind of like
are used to and that is where our
partners and integration comes in so we
have a lot of partners working with us
or we are working with them in order to
provide their APRs and their
functionality and a rich the bank
personality that we are delivering and
some of them needs this more synchronous
communication in the way that they are
designed so in those cases
we are using Google Cloud endpoints
which is a API management service by
Google out so as you see we try to use a
lot as most managed services as we can
get away with it has built-in support
for Java ta authentication so which is
the same authentication system that
firebase uses so when we have an
authenticated user in firebase or
communicating with rabbits we can also
authenticate this via the Cloud
endpoints API gateway it also have API
keys so if there's like other people
wanting outside of the our users that
are supposed to access these API so we
can provide them with API keys it's very
low overhead less than one millisecond
when we did our tracking and it comes
with all sort of logging and monitoring
built in so we don't need to kind of
build that on top as well so as I'm kind
of like alluded to or mentioned we
really don't have an operational
department it's not like we are building
this and then someone else will do and
go and manage this system for us it's
the developers that are on call and we
are really taking a lot of inspiration
from the site reliability engineering
and the site reliability workbooks
written by the asari team at Google we
these are the DevOps principles that we
kind of adhered here with automation and
working lean and monitoring and culture
of sharing so all of everything that is
set up and run on Google out is of
course setup using infrastructure as
code so everything is defined using
terraform in git and this is kind of
this is an example where you have four
container cluster where we have the
cluster definition and we are the worker
nodes and as you can see it's defined in
terraform configuration files and you
can check this into gate you can use the
workflow that developers are used to and
it's working very very good to do a
review validate that this is actually
working
and then
we deploy first test environment and
then to our production environment and
as we go along there we have actually
started creating pre I wouldn't say
approved but packages to make it easier
for the rest of the development team to
just like oh I need a database this or I
need a load balancer that we have
already made to terraform modules in
order to make that as easy as possible
and they just commit commit the change
or the new instance of it and then it
gets reviewed and approved and then it
gets rolled out so it's no like they
don't come to anyone and like oh I need
this it's them
proposing changes so for of course with
all of the automation and all everything
up and running we do need proper
observability to be able to kind of
sleep at night and know that this is
actually working so it's this is more
than monitoring observability is these
three pillars here so we have of course
your unstructured logs where everything
that is happening in the application is
just sent out to yesterday out to us
there that's fine but any one of you if
you have ever like parsed Splunk data
that's a terrible or that world of hurt
so we're we in order to get actually
metrics what is actually going on and
reporting and alerting on that that's
very building in metrics into the
systems that's aggregated data about how
many logins home and a failed logins
what's the different status codes for
this API here how many transactions and
so on as counters and and different data
types there and then you the third
pillar in observability is tracing so
when you have a lot of marker services
communicating and working sink in
injunction how do we actually see that
where the problem is it's originated
here but it's observed over here and how
do we trace back that that transaction
so we are currently heavily using
parameters all of our
in services are instrumented and
alerting and all of the dashboarding
goes through Prometheus metrics we have
our logs in stackdriver and we of course
get data and metrics for all of the
products and services that we are using
on Google cloud directly from
stackdriver no need to reinvent that and
we haven't come as far to as we would
have ideally would have liked on the
tracing part the plan was initially to
use open sensors which stackdriver has
very good support of visualizing traces
and spans but at this year's cube con it
was announced that the open sensors and
open tracing
projects are merging and becoming open
telemetry so we have just like waited a
little bit and kind of getting started
with that when the SDKs for go are ready
yeah so we went from idea to production
in just ten months I think that was a
credit incredible engineering effort and
our leadership and also like the
leadership were listening to what we
suggested and made it made put us in
charge more or less with how we was
supposed to or how we we're delivering
this and we are building on shoulders of
giants we are using services and
purchasing services wherever we can so
we don't have to reinvent the wheel
every time we of course are using the
API banking API backends from spa Bank
EMS which is the core banking
infrastructure and otherwise building
everything using Cuban ETS and firebase
so with that are there any questions I
don't see any I can't see
yeah yeah good question so the question
was if we have one perform reverse re or
multiple we have to that's because we
have some services that are shared
between the different environments so
for instance we have one container
registry we have one main DNS zone and
some storages remote storages for the
telephone configurations and then we
have as the other one auditor form
repository is for the actual environment
which is identical between the different
within the test environment and the
production environment just different
configuration variables
yeah well um thank you all for coming
and just feel free to ask me any
questions about Google out or Cuban ETS
or whatever you have I'm very happy to
talk video about all of these
technologies and much more thank you
[Applause]